Hi, I'm Sean Bennet - Course Architect with Udacity
I'm Colt McAnlis - Developer Advocate at Google
I'm Peter Lubbers - a Program Manager at Google.
Now HTML5 has a rich suite of functionality to build amazing experiences on the web.
This course is about leveraging those tools to build fun engaging games.
Now Colt here is going to be acting as our game expert
Hi I like games!
And Peter is going to be acting as our HTML 5 expert.
I love HTML 5.
Now there are two different ways you can enter this course. If you're not already familiar
with JavaScript or modern browsers, then we have an optional JavaScript crash
course for you to take. Now if you're already familiar with all of that, then
you can go ahead and skip that. And go straight to our canvas unit.
Can't wait to see you in class!